So, we had several questions related to
extending the search engine to do more things.
We had one from Lotus asking,
"How do we scan for viruses in the search results?"
and we had another one from McSpark asking,
"How do we handle relative lengths versus absolute lengths?"
>>So, it's great that you're thinking about things like this,
and we're not going to get to all of these things in this class.
Our goal in this class is really to learn about computer science,
and Python, and programming by building a search engine.
To do that we're going to keep the search engine as simple as possible.
What I hope many of you will do after the class--
or during the class if you have enough time,
is look at going beyond that--
many of these are interesting and important questions to think about
how to go beyond what we are doing in the class--
the search engine, the web crawler we'll build only deals with absolute links.
Dealing with relative links is certainly something
you'll be capable of doing on your own as the course progresses.
Dealing with safety indicators--that is a much tougher problem
to figure out if a given web page has malicious content on it.
But that is something many people work on for a lot of effort
at places like Google to try to figure out good ways to do that,
and it is an important thing for real search engines to do.
So, I hope as the course goes on,
you'll start to think of things that you want to do to improve the search engine.
We do have plans for a contest at the end of the course,
and so the best improvements will be things that will be recognized from that contest,
and we'll invite the winners out to Palo Alto to tell us more about them.